[Musique]
voilà un matin joyeux pour ces
adolescents placés au foyer de l'enfance
du département
bon bah les garçons on va on va partir
pour un camp de trois jours
aujourd'hui on rentrera mercredi et le
camp bin ça se passe à grand galet c'est
dans les eaux de langevin dans l'est de
la rivière langevin toutes les
structures du foyer de l'enfance pendant
les vacances ont un planning d'activités
bien complète alors que ça peut être des
activités ludiques culturelles ou des
camps comme par exemple le groupe de la
possession fils d'essence est parti à
look achète c'est pareil en camp où ils
vont découvrir plein d'activités après
ils partent sur mafate
non c'est vraiment la politique du foyer
de l'enfance de fer nord-est de faire
découvrir toute l'île de la réunion je
dis bien toutes l'île de la réunion à
tous les enfants qui sont accueillis au
collège
[Musique]
arrivé de l'autre côté de l'île la carte
postale est au rendez-vous et
directement la magie opère avec ces
jeunes et ça leur fait du bien en fait
qu'ils nous voient aussi dans un autre
notre contexte où nous forcément n'est
pas forcément là toujours temps de
rappeler les règles rappelé le cadre
c'est vraiment un le moment pour eux et
pour nous aussi de créer une relation de
confiance autres on a tendance à croire
que les jeunes qui sont placés sont des
délinquants des jeunes très difficile
mais en fait pour une bonne majorité il
son essence simplement en manquant
carences affectives et ont besoin
d'attention ils ont besoin qu'on fasse
attention à eux
ce sont ces cadres éducatifs motivés qui
proposent ces sorties hors les murs
partout dans l'île une dizaine de camps
sont organisés tous les ans chaque pas
de cette randonnée vers cape jaune est
l'occasion de grandir
et quand ils croisent du monde
l'inclusion a lieu c'est simplement un
groupe de jeunes en vacances
[Musique]
comme ils découvrirent
désormais en droit entre les membranes
connais même pas à se déguiser
jamais ni l'endroit là normalement
il ya pas
decaux bâtiment
être complice dans mon talent à chaque
enfant mérite ce sentiment de liberté
offert par les vacances une belle
manière d'aider notre jeunesse à devenir
les citoyens de demain
[Musique]